Film Courage: Can we talk about the time frame and
the conversation that you had with Howard [Barish]
about developing or redeveloping the script
for Skin In The Game because he saw it he said
I like it but...? Adisa, Filmmaker: Yeah, so
Howard had liked it and there was no commitment,
there was no commitment that he was gonna make
it. There was no... I mean we were just doing
the dance if you will and at the time because
it was benefiting the script and because it
was becoming better. I was like okay this this
works you know what i mean but I didn't know
if he was going to make it or not. I didn't
know at the end of this journey so I was still
sort of you know still trying to find a way
to do it independently like if you will like
i was still trying to raise a hundred thousand
dollars here i thought maybe we could have done
it for three hundred two hundred thousand
dollars so i was like okay well maybe at
one point i'm thinking we can do a fifty thousand
dollars so i was like because i was just you know
i was yeah i don't know if i was i'm not
gonna use one of these word desperate
but i wanted to make a movie like i wanted to
make a movie right but you got to be careful with
that word desperation because that desperate
causes you to rush a script into production
being desperate causes you to uh oversee like
over overlook certain things like the script may
not mechanically work or maybe have problems but
she's like oh god i just got to make this movie
so desperate is not a place you want to be you
know you talked about being on set sometimes
and you just don't want to be that guy who's
or girl woman who's on set being desperate you
want to be calm about the whole thing right and
so i had peace of mind during the whole process
but i didn't know if he was going to make
it or not and so i was looking for other
at that time probably you know seeing how we could
do it for a hundred thousand dollars or whatnot
um and it was it was a year i mean you look
up but you know a year goes by kind of fast
like you're like uh wait a minute three
months have passed you know you do a rewrite
two months to pass you give him a script it
takes him a month to read it you know then
he gives you back he calls you there's notes then
he travels he's hey boom he's he's at a sundance
film festival you know so then that month is down
and then he comes back and then he has to gear up
for this commercial thing so it's like i'm working
so it doesn't feel like a year but a year goes by
right before before we make the movie yeah and
the script is constantly getting better and
it's constantly evolving and we're constantly in
communication and talking you know about you know
you know what it could look like and yeah so then
sending him revisions and then he gives you notes
yeah i was sending revisions he had had uh uh mike
nell is uh is over there he's a co-producer over
there and mike would give us notes i would go
sometimes i'd walk in we'd sit down we'd talk
they'd both give me notes we could change this
whatever we think about this and it was never like
dictatorial you know they would just be
making like like suggestions you know i
think it would be better if we did this and blah
blah because howard in his company they really
i think they protect or they they respect the
vision of the filmmaker right so it wasn't like
they were trying to change my vision at all
it was always about like how do we make this
a better house this can be a better house this
can be better what if we add this what if we
take this away you know like uh the ending was
a big was a big thing for us you know because
sundance and usually independent film usually
like places like sunday like darker endings
right they like gritty endings and so you know we
played with the ending a lot you know but then i
think there was uh who told me this yeah one
of my survivor women told me don't make it uh
a dark ending she told me even though the reality
for most of these girls is they don't get out
right a lot of them truthfully either succumb to
drugs you know uh they get worn out and they uh
some of them die you know i mean you know
the lifespan of a prostitute is only like
seven years yeah and so you know or the od so it
becomes it's like a very grim experience and so
but she told me do not show the ending so in our
movie i don't want to give away any spoilers but
there was a point where the hair uh the lead girl
gets caught into the life and doesn't come back
but this person the survivor told me she said
don't do that because she says the pimps will
use it as a recruiting tool and they'll
use it to say look see she couldn't get out
you see see this movie this is the truth
this is your reality so don't even try
and everybody it really it meant something to
me so i shared that with howard and them too
you know and uh i think it impacted all of us you
know in terms of the way we shaped the the movie
toward the end yeah did anybody try to talk you
out of making the movie in that they thought
maybe you can't get distribution because of the
subject matter distributors might be scared of it
yeah well that's that that's where howard was key
but i remember one of our first meetings and he
repeated this a lot he said listen this can move
you after we finish it it can be a paperweight
it can uh it can be an exercise of futility
it can sit up there on the bookshelf there
it's just uh you know um you know just it's
like just collecting dust right it may go
nowhere right he was very real i mean like
i was like i mean you know i mean i was like
you know like because that's that
wasn't my thinking right at all
but he had again he's an experienced producer and
he's done this a number of times and then when we
met again we were getting ready to make the movie
he said listen this can either sit on the shelf it
can be a paperweight or it can be an exercise
of utility like he said that exact same thing
and um do you still want to do this you know and i
said yeah you know and but see he had been to the
other side of the mountain he had been the journey
before so he knew right so even now as we get skin
in the game out there to audiences and it's been
a great journey it's been a great journey right um
but we didn't get into sundance we didn't get into
tribeca you know we didn't get into toronto uh we
didn't get into south by southwest we didn't get
into any of the top tier festivals right so that
was a whole year because if you know anything
about festivals they want to premiere your film
first the top tier ones if they don't get
access to your film first like say if you
premiered at chicago international film festival
and then sunday and say okay we want your movie
we want the exclusive rights to the premiere
and you're like well we already premiered it
at chicago they're like well we don't want
it so that happens a lot so you have to
um gauge it and we had to go a whole like almost
cycle year of trying to get into the big festivals
then when we didn't get into the big festivals
then we could back up and say okay we didn't get
into all the big ones right and why do you want
the big ones because the distributors are there
because the buyers are there because the national
press is there right the attention is there so you
want to hold out for those festivals but when you
don't get it then you say okay now what are the
second tier festivals and uh so we were fortunate
i mean we were fortunate in the sense that we
premiered at urban world in new york in september
which is a great festival you know we had a great
premiere there then we went up to
uh whistler film festival in canada
and then we ended with the pan african
film festival and we won best director
best first feature film right so yeah it was
uh it's been a journey but to your point about
how we're talking about the paperweight but
now we're in the process is distributing it
right and distributing it is almost as hard
as making it like when you ask yourself
what is the hardest part writing the script
making it or distributing it i'm almost like
well distributing it is hard as hell because now
you got to get it out there to people people have
to see it you want people to see it and so um yeah
it takes it's and we're an indie film so it's like
ch choo choo choo choo choo yes you can yes you
can choo choo choo choo choo you know so plus it's
not as sexy to be distributing it yeah when you're
on set oh yeah you're you're even though there's
stressful moments and then you made another point
about the subject matter so howard was also very
clear this is this is not a popular subject
matter or a lot of people don't want to see
that kind of thing it's in the shadows right and
so even my wife for instance never read the script
even when we finished the film she never saw
it and she was actually when i was writing the
scriptures like how can you write that how can
you you know i mean it created something for her
in terms of just the subject matter and we had two
little girls so it was and i understand it right
and so i knew just translated from that to what
howard was saying it's not gonna be an easy sell
and you know for whatever reason people are
not gonna just be it didn't matter how good
the film is just to be drawn to the subject
but i would say i'm willing to roll the dice
in spite of all that he said let's roll the
dice knowing what he knew is a businessman
he said let's roll the dice yeah it seems
like you're attracted or you're willing to
explore dark subject matter and and know that a
lot of people may not want to see they may know
about young children working in mines and it's
horrible but i do i really want to spend years
why do you think you're willing to go there
well because as much as you talk about the
dark subject matter and the darkness of the uh why
do i go there i'm an optimist and so i like to see
the light in the darkness you know sometimes i
think the light is in the darkness right and so
i'm gonna go there because i'm still fighting
for the hope and the possibility right
so i'm never going to tell a story where it's just
dark right and then at the ending it's it's like
unconscionable and you know i'm always going to
there's going to be a spin on it right or there's
going to be a take on it so in the diamond mine
thing you know we got the kids out of the mines
you know we funded them in soccer and we put them
in schools so that was like there was there was
something that came out of that right and so
with the girls it was important for me to tell
the subject matter but it was also important
to tell that one story of possibility and hope
you know the girl that made it the girl that
did get out and so we can cling on to that you
know so i'm not afraid of the darkness but
you know for me it there has to be that um
that thing where i'm not gonna just live in there
just you know wallow in it yeah there's got to
be some um some hope some possibility so i'm
always fighting for the possibility in the hope.
Question For The Viewers: What did
you like about this video?